this chandelier is quite a showstopper
it stretches more than three feet high
and wide with 24 elegant arms it's
decorated with clear and red crystal and
a gilded hurricane shade over each light
to make the crystal they melt silica
sand in a furnace
along with lead potash and several other
ingredients the materials combine to
make crystal heavier and more sparkling
than glass to make each chandelier armed
a crystal blower gathers some molten
crystal on the end of his blowpipe then
shapes the arm with a series of blocks
and moulds he makes a channel down the
mill for the arms electrical wiring next
to master crystal blowers work together
to pull and twist the crystal into the
arms rope like design this maneuver
requires tremendous expertise to achieve
the correct diameter these craftsmen
must stretch the crystal exactly right
next they put it in a chandelier arm
mold and snip off the excess on both
ends they blow cold air to solidify the
crystal next a pair of craftsmen make
the bowl shaped bottom of the chandelier
using traditional techniques they place
molten crystal in a mold then place the
mold in a press
the crystal chandelier parts are cooled
down in an oven straight out of the
furnace the crystal is twenty two
hundred and eighty degrees a crystal
blower makes the hurricane shades first
he rolls a starting shape at the end of
his blowpipe then with pliers he narrows
and stretches one end to form a neck by
now the crystal is cold so he reheats it
before continuing next he inserts the
crystal into a foot pedal operated mold
installed in the floor he then turns the
pipe and blows through it to expand the
crystal to the mold shape
every part of the crystal chandelier is
handmade and the entire chandelier is
manually assembled the arms have a light
socket at one end wired to a connector
at the other all 24 arms mount to a
round tray beneath it the connectors
link to the main wires running down the
center of the chandelier the chandeliers
ornate bottom hides at all
this stunning crystal chandelier cast
sparkling light easily making it the
focal point of the room weighing in at
over 150 pounds this grand chandelier
makes a big bold design statement